(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] Wilbur Force, my friend.
You used to be The King in the Ring.
You wrestled for glory.
You punished your opponents.
You stayed in shape.
What happened?
- [William] We just weren't
doing many shows anymore.
You kind of lose a bit of hope, I guess.
And I did.
I miss the physicality of a match,
I miss cheating and getting away with it,
and I definitely miss my friends.
- If someone asks you
why you're into wrestling
and saying that it's all
fake, what would you say?
- Well, I'd say get in the ring
and have a go and see what it's like.
And see the hard work, dedication,
the athleticism some people have.
(groaning)
Someone goes down and it
looks like a nasty fall
and you have no idea whether they're
actually legitimately hurt or not.
(groaning)
Even though you're
sitting there and you know
that you're watching
a bit of a soap opera,
you've got this mystery about it.
- You never know what part
is real and what's fake?
- Yeah.
(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] Wilbur Force,
you will teach me your art.
Dare I remember your best self.
- What if my wrestling character
embodied your weaknesses?
Like laziness.
I could wear your mask.
- I don't want it to be public knowledge
that I've got sleep apnea.
It's not something that I
want to wave the flag of.
Hey, I'm a failure, wicked, awesome!
- That's how I pitched the film, though.
- "Wilbur, can we make our film
please, about 'ze wrestling?"
I'm like, alright, sure.
Next minute, "Wilbur,
why are you so fat, yah?"
"Why are you so fatty-fatty?"
- It's like you just
want to show me around.
This is my friend, he does nothing.
Come and laugh at him.
- No, it's about.
- That's what you're
trying to do, isn't it?
- It's about you and me and me setting out
to make this film and
get you off your ass.
- [Wilbur] So I'm a little
tool so you can create drama.
You're just using it, you're
not being a friend at all.
I don't wanna do this anymore.
- You're mic-ed up.
- Take this shit off.
Pull over!
- Will.
- (beep) off.
(car door slams)
- For (beep) sakes.
- Will!
- [Wilbur] (beep) off.
(beeping)
(scuffling and grunting)
(car whoosing)
- [Narrator] Wilbur Force,
Wilbur Force, Wilbur Force.
(dramatic music)
(muffled shouting)